I'm Evan Carmichael and today's
one-minute Monday is over-deliver like
crazy stop beating your head trying to
find new customers and new prospects and
out there all the time
the fastest way to get your business to
where you want to be is over deliver
like crazy to your current customers and
the people in your network here's a
quick story when I was hired by one of
my clients they paid me $500 to write a
300 word article for their site that
firing the box for 300 words that's a
great deal I get a link back to my
website why not they hired me and nine
of the people to do the same thing
those nine people you know what they did
they wrote 300 words just like they were
expected what did I do
I wrote 1500 words I added a video I
promoted to my newsletter I put out my
social media channels and as a result
had way more people visiting and
engaging with my content than any of the
other nine guys what happened I got
hired and that 50 that 500 dollar
contract turned into a $50,000 a year
contract those other nine guys got
canned and I got a lot more referral
business as a result so stop stop
beating your heads trying to go out and
get new customers your best path here is
to over-deliver like crazy to your
current customers and the people in your
network you want people to leave every
engagement every conversation with you
saying WOW if you do that people will
talk about you belief like this video
thumbs up below and leave a comment
click my face subscribe to the channel
thank you so much I'll see you soon